welcome everyone to the Tuesday night
lecture on end games and if the team is
going to be a game of mine actually well
we're very quickly out of the opening
with transition to a very sharp mill
game where I conduct a very strong
attack because of one in accuracy by my
opponent and quickly win the game in
about 20 21 22 moves opponent is a very
serious one it's not a you know weak
opponent is you know I think you know
feeding master eugenia at twenty
twenty-three hundred pledged so I'm
playing with the black pieces and then
we will also have some endgame positions
after so d4 he played Knight f6 again
this is the American open tournament as
well c4 e6 I'm trying to play the
nimzo-indian defense but right away he
plays g3 he's not letting me do that
what opening he's trying to play raise
your hand if you know this opening yes
the Catalan he is trying to play the
Catalan here mm-hmm
so he I played d5 Knight f3 and the main
lines of Catalan Bishop before Bishop e7
these are all main main lines but I play
Bishop before check which I usually play
and Bishop e7 is the main move in this
position but I did not play that I play
Bishop d6 to complicate the position a
little bit steer away from the main
theory to make sure that opponent will
start to think and he did start think
because this is not the main move my
move is Bishop e7 so now he plays Bishop
to g2 developing his Bishop
I Castle he castles and then I played c6
my plan is to go 90 d7 next and at the
right moment maybe perhaps to play e5 to
break through and now I was expecting
Quincy to or perhaps b3 but he played
different move he surprised me a little
bit Bishop f4
just trying to exchange the pieces I
took Quincy to 9b d7 Quincy - and you
know I was expecting he will just
develop his night play III kind of solid
position for white but now I want you to
take control of this game and try to
play the most folk black what is the
next move that I need to play here it's
very important that I play this move in
order to I can finish my development so
I can complete the development DC you
can but then he goes Queen takes c4 and
it's not totally clear you know it's not
totally clear what else what else we can
do here
DC is one thing huh that is the
excellent move the idea is to go Bishop
d7 you know I want to go Bishop e7 and
at the right moment to play c5 to open
up to open up the position but now he
played instead of Knight b d2 or e3 he
took and now his position is going to
get very complicated very very
complicated now I want you to think
don't rush here and try to find a move
that I played from here on you're in
control to win this game I want this
game quiet quite quickly here first in
accuracy of the game by my opponent and
then he continued to play in the same
team ino aggressively trying to pursue
something but what he was pursuing was
not the right thing to do so let's see
if you can find a way to take advantage
of it so what do i do now
yes well I he just took my pawn he just
took my pawn and I need to take it back
okay yeah yeah so yeah okay so you want
to take the pawn back or not
well we it's important to take the pawn
back because then he's going to threaten
a capture here or capture here as well
and he takes again and he takes your
bishop that's not very good you lose a
piece tink tink don't rush don't need to
play that complicated he took your pawn
we need to capture back but we have
several options I want you to be able to
make the right decision yes in the back
it's possible but position will be very
static you know and it's not going to be
easy to win a very static position like
this 93 Bishop a6 Luke FC 1 the
structure is fixed
not too many palm breaks here and
position is about equal he will put the
pawn only 3 and very equal equal
position here I want to I want little
bit more complications here that's why I
didn't take back with this pawn
immediately what else do you see here
what is my other alternative here to
take back with yes
well c6 pawn is fine it's not a bad move
at all that's what the other person
suggested as well it's not a bad move at
all but I want you to play the best move
City is a normal ordinary move I want
you to play better in the back correct
answer Knight takes d5 is the correct
answer because now Knight is putting
pressure on the weak pawn on f4 that's a
weak policy
it's unprotected so now I take with the
night and I'm attacking on it putting
pressure on it so now if he takes right
away I'm not going to move my rook away
I'm just going to go be space six to
conduct an attack on the pawn and go
rook c8 as well that's what I'm planning
to do here okay so he saw that and
continued in the same team you know
playing very actively Knight g5 jumping
in threatening checkmate see this is
like you know very tough you know when
opponent jumps like this right away very
aggressively you have to be very calm
and alert you cannot just start
panicking
some people get you know worried
immediately and then they start playing
passive moves and eventually they get
into trouble you cannot do that you have
to stay sharp and calculate calculate
concrete calculation not just you know
one move a couple of move calculation
here what is the correct move you have
did you calculate the consequences of a
45 that's one thing you have to
calculate also who can tell me why not
g6 the very natural move g6 blocking the
screen this is not a good move but you
see why this is not a good move tactical
tactical idea here you have
it actually weakens the position of the
king as well so he will take attacking
my rook and if I do the same idea as in
the previous position Bishop a six now
tactic that better tactic shine he has a
very nice tactic yes he's got it he's
got it yes Knight X is six sacrificing
the night he takes he says check I move
away he's like this completely crushing
my position you see that one weakening
pawn move and then position gets very
weak so correct move is nine seven f6
but calculation needed because he could
play e4 Knight x f4 correct and E 5 now
this Knight is under attack if you move
it the way he takes on a shovel and says
checkmate h6 is the only move but the
good news is it's a winning move only
move but a winning move now you attack
him he attacks you you don't think about
deep and you attack him counter attack
I'm gonna be a counter attack so takes
takes takes take look at that superior
knight on a 4 here it's very nicely
placed you go see if you can even go
here we should be 7 and excellent
position ok
so when I played this he probably should
have played he three or something his
position is not that bad but now he
wanted it to he wanted to play the most
principled way so he took my palm now
you have a very strong move here that
you need to find development is the key
remember to success in the opening you
have a chance you develop your pieces
actively who can show me a good
developing move here a six what don't
rush Bishop only seven would be
attacking but not actively I want to
active move I know but that just attacks
the Queen and if I move away your Bishop
is not on a very active square here you
have a better move here you look at them
but Knight is very active here let's now
move the knight let's try to move a
piece that is not developed so that way
we can get all the pieces developed we
can have what's called complete
development okay always pay attention to
that okay develop the pieces that are
not developed so we can complete the
development there is another square for
that Bishop more active Bishop a6
correct yes Bishop a6 activating the
Bishop attacking on it too and now you
are getting ready to play which move
rook c8 to gain additional tempo when
you make a move attacking something we
call that a temple gaining temples got
it
tempos now he realized trouble he cannot
protect both pawns
so he played the move rook e1 thinking
ok he will protect this and if I take
care he will take my queen but now what
are you going to do
of course Roxy it bring the rook into
the game Quinn is almost trapped he's
lucky he has the square now and this is
the moment that you need to find a very
special move don't rush to three minutes
thinking okay to three minutes everybody
thinking and then you can raise your
hand because this is the move that is
going to turn the tables okay and then
Bach will have a big advantage my bishop
is under attack keep that in mind in
your calculations okay very impressive
do you see the follow-up correct
Dasia takes e to a fantastic idea he has
to take because otherwise his pawn
structure is completely ruined now you
go check and now you take his King is
very very weak here as you can see it's
very exposed
but you had to calculate deeper did you
see this move this is what you had to
see now
this is what you had to see now another
stunning the move here you have you
could that but you could it's an okay
movie abut you have something stronger
you you don't want to exchange Queens
here because he will take you you want
to keep your Queen because I want to
make him here and there is no better
piece than a queen to use as an attacker
okay
the queen is your attackers queen is
your attacker fantastic yes fantastic
idea Queen d5 now the threat is Queen -
G - checkmate
Bishop cannot capture because rook is
peeling that Bishop okay pinning it got
it so what to do he has to take it he's
got no choice he's got to take it now
what are you going to do Queen takes
Knight check correct decision King h1 be
very very careful now there is only one
move that winning here the other moves
who fail don't rush you see it that will
check it that will check the answer not
check double check your answer
only one move will bring you the victory
here that special move
9x3 excellent move threatening checkmate
from here threatening checkmate from
here
checkmate from two different locations
how's your move good excellent I have to
take I've got no choice I have to accept
the sacrifice now what's the follow-up
check until now my opponent that you
know he is still hey now but when I
announced the next move when I play the
next one he just realized it's
completely hopeless what is the next
room that is going to make his position
hopeless you could that but look for
another idea yep takes b2 is good
because now this is under attack as well
that's under attack as well okay and he
cannot go anywhere okay
the roof is trapped rook is trapped and
that's it you will win this game right
now he realized he's losing his rook and
he will be down exchange and at least
one or two pounds as well so he decided
the best thing to do is just to resign
here because what else to do if he takes
here I take he takes I take his position
is just terrible here I have rook for a
knight extra pawn pawns are terribly
weak so that's just a easy win here for
me okay any questions about this game
this is a strong 2,300 player feeder
mustache
okay what about 92 who can tell me the
difference between 93 and 92 because I
was thinking about both of them are
winning but actually not and I was very
you know cautious because you know I
thought about 92 actually but then I
realized 92 there is a flaw in it
okay 92 he takes now we go check what is
he going to do yes
going back he takes and he escapes
protects the look I'm still better here
I have a lot of pawns but this is like a
different game here we're talking about
different game well he's got a piece I
got a lot of pawns so I'll still like my
position but I don't think I'm winning
here she's just it's a big fight and
plus Knight is she was just winning so I
just calculated that I had to seal this
actually right here right here I had to
see all this
you know when I played Bishop a6 I went
for this line I to see it 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 because if I don't have this move
right this whole line is not going to
work for me so this is an example of
calculation in the middle game okay
right see very quick transition from the
opening to a meal game because opening
ended actually we are on our own here
there were only like couple of games
played here this is basically a new
territory here that from here on it's
just nobody analyzes nobody played this
this is not analyzed so it's an imino
game here okay well very good good job
so we're going to do an over review of
the game to make sure everybody remember
this game ok very recent and fresh game
this game helped me to win the American
Open tournament okay go ahead raise your
hand if you know black moves here it's
only 22 moves the entire game continue
what's the next move
what opening is he playing Catalan
Catalan okay remember that what is my
move against Catalan not yet get the
center get that Center now Bishop before
check and everybody go back we should be
seven only they take on the two or maybe
the another move but I paid a little bit
more rare a move Bishop d6 bringing it
back Bishop g2 continue now yeah
absolutely I want to have the square for
my queen and also I want to go see six
ninety seven and eight forty five break
if I put a [ __ ] 27 I don't have any of
those ideas it's a bit more conservative
defense you know but here I'm playing
somebody a little bit lower than me so I
want to go for offense in a little bit
more active
okay so castle safety of the King is is
what number one priority remember yeah
very important next c66 get that square
for your Bishop okay get that square for
your Bishop and strengthen that Center
exchange now develop and now the problem
I'm facing is my light square bishop I
am not sure what to do with it I didn't
want to get it out but it's not easy so
I need to get a bishop somewhere where
correct decision again yes the idea to
go Bishop b2 now
attack he counter-attacks now this is
where he jumped in and tried to create
problems for me what are we going to do
specify specify which one spread night
797 f6 that's how you write it down as
well
you put night 7 f6 protecting against it
if he plays before we take don't be
afraid you've got this okay you've got
h6 okay so he took my pawn playing very
principled chess now go ahead
you mean a6 Bishop to e6 right attacking
it he protects which piece ones will
come in into the action here and you
want to come in with the temples
excellent job rook c8 a4 very nice move
Bishop it takes that's that's
extraordinary move because completely
rules his pawn structure of course I
also had to calculate this move but if
he does this you take he takes Knight f4
is very neat threatening this
threatening this threatening this you
tell me which one you want to do it how
you want to do this completely crushing
yeah yeah this didn't happen yeah this
is winning mm-hmm he didn't play like
this because that's just winning for me
so he took who wants to follow it
through here you force this rook to come
up to do what
you got it yes check and only now we're
going to do what
correct correct idea yes attacking the
rook Naugles rook c2 proposing the
exchange of the rooks
what are we going to do here what are we
going to do here are we going to accept
this who is going to find that special
move yes Queen d5 threatening checkmate
that's a very strong treta now Klinge
you to mate so he takes continued check
special special idea Knight h3 yes
threatening mate on G 1 and F 2 takes
check thank you very much
winning the rook and the game all right
nice and quick energetic Victoria cancer
you know strong opponent so I wish all
the games are like this you know short
and good you know and win for me but
unfortunately I don't like to play you
know long games anymore I'm just getting
tired you know I like short and quick
you know like we're you know like kind
of you win like this game the game
against previous game I showed you
against I am Kiera
so like aggressive attacking wins you
know but this doesn't happen too often I
just got lucky a couple of wins like
this in one tournament normally the
resistance is you know but this time
yeah just doze okay very good I have
couple of very special positions for you
okay that I prepare today so let's start
that with this one it's
you're black in this game black to play
and try to find a winning continuation
don't rush don't rush this is pretty
advanced and interesting position you
need to analyze this you are under a
check and it looks like you'll be losing
your pawn on h7 so it's not even clear
why you should be even trying to play
well playing for the win
that's the question where to put the
King so many squares the problem with
that move is he takes your knight you
have to take back with something right
which pawn this one or this one left
this one then he takes I'm not sure
where is my advantage here I'm not so
sure enough if I even have advantage so
King e6 same thing I take the night and
I take on h7 again I'm not sure what is
my edge
aha
King f8 why King f8 now go deeper go
deeper now I can take your pawn on h7
your king is not ideally placed on a
fade your King on f8 is no good because
it's cut off the worst place for the
king is to be cut off on that background
remember right it's getting cut off so
what are you going to do
can you do it in your head without me
putting it on the board can you do it in
your head why what's going to happen
after that and if it goes backwards no
I'll keep working keep working you don't
give up here don't give up on a great
idea it's just gotta go a little deeper
you know to make it work that's what
happens we sometimes quit too early yes
gentlemen I take you don't rush don't
rush
f 3 correct of course f3 everyone if he
takes check winning the bishop so he
goes back here what you going to do
check check how about that
you see how that happen and if he goes
here what are you going to do check
check
he is a rookie ADA are you sure about
that how about you come up a little bit
a little bit come up a little bit come
up a little bit come up you come here so
he cannot do this you know he cannot do
this because the night is out there if
you pay h3 I just take it
checkmate any questions you have it's a
mating net
okay who the fleet King f8 raise your
hand in a real tournament game it's a
it's the most unusual move because you
know you don't want to go backwards
that's like the first thing you learn
right in in games never go backwards
never have your King cut off but know
there are consequences okay there are
consequences concrete consequences now
now he goes here what you cannot do
you could Hammadi get more active more
active did you calculate the smooth
solutions oke remember that's a Swiss
Shinsuke in-between move swish and suck
and then we take it otherwise you are
going to lose your rock okay not good
okay very nice very very nice okay so we
got that one okay excellent
now the next position I have for you
it's also very interesting let me set up
again similar position where you need to
find a way out of it okay so let's see
yeah another very similar position but
this one Europe exchange actually this
is a advanced stuff we're doing here
okay we're not doing anything light here
this is very serious
analytical work we're going to do here
okay now black to play and you need to
find the Nydia something that we can get
out of this okay
don't rush the problem we have is our a
knight is dropped okay and he wants to
play like something like Bishop a6 and
Bishop d3 okay so he wants to do
something like that
and the night is going to be trapped and
he will wind upon and enjoy this
advantage enjoy it
look
Oh Ruki six yeah but then he will just
do the same thing Bishop takes Bishop d3
and block that file take your time
because this you gotta calculate you got
to do serious calculation here again I
want to mention to you my thread white
wants to go white just wants to go
Bishop to a6 okay then put this here
okay that's what he wants to go here and
here and then win the night so if you
move the King he will just gladly do
that so that's you now you have two
moves you have two moves before he does
that create something create something
powerful okay time is ticking here very
important to do it otherwise we're going
to lose this game two bishops are too
powerful for a session how how we can
take that one they should that would be
great but I'm not sure how we can do
that really you need to play like a
grandmaster here okay
grandmaster idea you know his threat I
told you find a way that he can make
this thread difficult for him to do
because that's the only way he can trap
your knight
we're trying to save this position here
I mean black end up winning the game but
first let's try to save the night okay
let me give you a little hint when he
puts that Bishop on d3 you can need to
have some kind of pawn break or
something there you know because
otherwise you'll just cement the
position okay so think about to
potentially having some pawn break or
something out there on a four and if he
captures you
he would capture you know tough on her
tough one real challenge but you guys
getting closer you're looking at the
right direction now you know you're
looking at the right direction now yes
yes but that should be backed up by a
precise tactics okay by precision g5
Bishop a6f for take take visually looks
like he is getting us looks like he is
getting us here pawn to f3 tanks with a
rock on the night he takes a clause
artfully closer
no this thing think this is the moment
you gotta bail out bail out that night
okay
that night is stuck how are you going to
be allowed in the back Italy a little
problem
little problem is this okay you open up
his bishop oh I'm happy that Russian huh
this is what you need guys stuff endgame
positions like this to get better in the
Edit endgame you know now your knight is
going to be gone so you can't really
think too much here you've got to do
this okay
you've got to do this time you're
running out of time here
denne no no this position not knows no
g5 here
I mean b5 no no don't worry about that
you look rook takes DT that's what
you're referring to correct answer
Bravo okay wait wait one second let me
explain why is this correct answer maybe
you can explain take right now he wants
to play f3 cement the position okay it
looks like after this you simply need to
resign because your rook is hanging your
knight is hanging and if you are
planning to do this clever move guess
what it doesn't work because I've got
your knight trapped in a corner papa got
it but always the bat yeah don't panic
don't panic okay position has ideas in
it King takes rook I want to take the
rock I want to take your rook so what
you're going to do first you cannot
afford to lose your rook you can lose
some other things but not the rook move
it correct where
better keep the eye on that you gotta
keep that eye on this okay how about d5
and if it takes what do you have decoy
also deflection haha there you go you
see how that works
deep calculation huh now you win so now
you cannot prove well he is kind of
stuck here it's not easy to do anything
it's not easy for you to do anything
also but at least you're not losing here
I think it's not so easy to win this
position but I think you're definitely
in the driver's seat here so you have to
go here take bishop takes and 94
now your 13 check this difference okay
you know you're better here King to see
six black is up upon and good chances
okay let's go back to do this one more
time because this is quite a difficult
position for you so let's see first move
what we're going to do to create a palm
break keep working
locking it and if I take it beautiful
yes if it takes it pawn f3 check this is
the key to remember you had to sue these
cities here to go for it because without
this move this whole thing doesn't work
so as to maybe go here Knight is trapped
again and tactic
what's the tactic 1394 check you just
put it on c6 okay excellent job any
questions about this position in the
beginning it looked like tough it looked
kind of grim you know the night is
trapped
he's got pair of the bishops position is
static you were trying a lot of
breakthroughs c4 was suggested didn't
work b5 was suggested didn't work some
other ideas were thrown out there but
you had to be patient and create the
break g5 f4 is a very difficult idea to
find in a real game actually it's very
you know whoever found this idea is a
very impressive you know because it's a
very tough idea to find because you
don't look too strong here he looks
stronger you know with this pawn so you
don't look too strong but you got that
idea g5f for in order to break through
yes
this is from a game and I can even tell
you who played this game this game is
played between this game is played
between left
sokka's and jonathan Spielman hastings
tournament nineteen
87 okay so sockets Spielman Hastings and
actually you will see these two
positions a little bit similar the
previous one and this one it's the same
game yes just the first one was a later
part of it it's the same game two
extraordinary positions okay this is the
early stages of the game and then I show
you that one that was the late stage of
the game you know where you find that
idea with the King f8 okay
okay excellent any other questions you
have for me well thank you everyone for
attending the class